after a very great that we can see you
hear your own country by the time you
are filmmaker and for many people in our
country the Netherlands you became known
to your movie Timbuktu which got an
Oscar nomination why is it that you made
this movie people for me the author it's
really in my movie because I when the
Sun was come from the place we come to
the city Timbuktu is very well city the
city of Islam which means what it's the
city of confession list of love the city
of doing Ascension and and those people
come and decide one more one day to stop
this kind of
and one years dis duels occupied but in
the West media people talk only about
German thousand thousand people Muslim
and I decide to talk about everything in
the Pacific we change the situation
pacific and for me it was very important
I filmmaker to talk about selfish Exeter
they are very simple they protest
against this vision many people in
Europe also due to the ideology of
right-wing politics
Islam is fanaticism is my origins
language you're conscious you are
situate to decide that Islam is like
that as a filmmaker as an artist do you
have an this means because they use the
person
after 911 nobody try against fine people
try to interpret that is its religion
Islam no I cannot accept 10 guy who take
one plane the chilla modern 3000 person
the way of my religion is not my vision
the size of my life many last question
the Marxist philosopher Walter Benjamin
once said there is no civilization with
no built on barbarism how do you
understand this I'm not exactly how to
answer discussion which they want to
tell another sentence come from the same
proportion
he said he never can accept the promise
of great country great civilization
because you know it will be built in the
life of check the dose esq also said and
for you as an artist that's an important
idea he said only beauty can save the
world absolutely you believe that why
you know beauties for me when the woman
and the end she tossed harm her cry some
this beauty it means you cannot you can
be you can beat me but you cannot forbid
to sink my mind dispute when young
people play the football without more
it's also beauty they say your decision
stupid auto you don't want i play that's
very important that is the poem that you
can be barbary and killed many people
that you cannot tell you manage this
week it's true your responsibility is to
to to educate for your child small to be
better to be more you the server's not
to decide to make easy
yes